[Music]
after hits like the Super Mario Brothers
movie and The Last of Us movie and
series adaptations of video games are
totally on the rise in this Koch
original We introduce you to the next
big projects that we are particularly
looking forward
to director Eli Roth will bring us one
of the most popular Shooters on the big
screen next year Borderlands will tell
us the story of the infamous treasure
hunter Lilith she reluctantly returns to
her home planet and sets off in search
of an Alien Vault that supposedly
contains advanced technology the
adaptation of the famous game series
features a phenomenal cast multiple
Oscar winner Kate blanchat will take on
the leading role of Lilith Kevin Hart
Jack Black Edgar Ramirez and jam Lee
Curtis will likewise be part of this
film sadly the project is not under the
best of circumstances in addition to
several additional shoots with a new
director the screenwriter also dropped
his name from the film which doesn't
speak volumes for anyone's faith in the
quality of the project the release date
is August 9th 2024 which means we will
probably be able to see for our elves
what the movie has to offer around that
time the iconic Hedgehog Sonic will be
speeding across screens again next year
after his last adventure in 2022 Sonic
and his friends will now have to deal
with Shadow the Hedgehog whether Jim
Carrey will also return as Dr Robotnik
is still unclear after all the actor has
announced his retirement Sonic the
Hedgehog 3 attracted attention thanks to
an unusual solution that allowed filming
to begin despite the actor strike the
movie was initially shot without the
participation of the actors and the the
focus was exclusively on the CGI
characters as these are set to play a
bigger part in the third installment
anyway Sonic 3 will be released on
December 20th
2024 one of the biggest phenomena in
video game history is also being made
into a movie Warner announced back in
2014 that a Minecraft movie was in the
works now the plan is coming to fruition
as the movie will hit theaters in 2025
not too much information is known about
the plot yet but according to some leaks
it will be about the Journey of a girl
who travels to the blocky world with
with a group of adventurers to save it
from the Ender Dragon the game's fun and
creativity could therefore also be the
focus of the Cinematic adaptation with
Jason mimoa and Pedro Pascal two actors
have already been cast who are very
popular due to their likable nature
Pascal was previously convincing in the
series adaptation of The Last of Us
Minecraft is slated to be released on
April 4th
2025 Netflix is teaming up with
developers the coalition to make an
adaptation of the third person shooter
Gears of War the first part of the game
sold over five million copies worldwide
led to numerous sequels novels and
comics and is regarded as one of the
most popular representatives of its
genre the video game is about a
civilization on the brink of Extinction
fighting against an overwhelming alien
threat on the planet Sarah in Hollywood
a movie adaptation of the story has been
planned for quite some time and now
Netflix has secured the rights the
streaming giant has also signed on
renowned screenwriter John Spates who
co-wrote Dune for example Zack Snyder
was interested as well and is considered
a strong Contender for the director's
position there is also specul as to
whether Dwayne Johnson will take on the
starring role of Marcus Phoenix in
addition to the film adaptation an
animated series aimed specifically at
adults is also planned the movie doesn't
have a release date
yet a movie adaptation of metal gear
solid has also been on Hollywood's to-do
list for some time concrete plans for a
movie were made as early as 2006 were
postponed indefinitely in 2010 in 2012
Uncharted producer AI ID brought the
project back to life and was able to win
over Jordan Voit Roberts as a capable
director for the project Roberts was
previously in charge of the Blockbuster
Kong Skull Island likewise it was
announced that Oscar Isaac will play the
role of Solid Snake Isaac commented on
the project in 2022 saying that they
were still working on it and that the
film was definitely still on his radar
it all depended on finding the right
story at the time he even assumed that
filming would presumably be able to
start in 2022 but since then nothing has
been heard about the Project Metal Gear
Solid revolves run the genetically
modified super agent Solid Snake who has
to deal with powerful enemies we will
will likely have to keep on waiting for
a specific release date a while
longer the samurai Adventure ghost of
tsushima developed by Sucker Punch was a
hit among fans of Japanese mythology in
2020 it particularly appealed with a
beautiful Game World references to the
Akira kurasawa films and a captivating
Story the game focuses on the Mongol
evasion of the island of tsima which is
part of Japan the player takes on the
role of the Samurai Jin Sakai who puts
up a fight against the Invaders due to
the Cinematic production of the game the
decision was made to adapt the material
for the big screen the director is to be
none other than John Wick director Chad
stahelski an absolute master in his
field and a big fan of the game himself
dilki has already confirmed that the
project is being worked on at full speed
and that he would like to turn it into a
two or 2 and a half hour movie a release
date for The Ghost of tsima movie is
sadly not known
yet HBO achieved a phenomenal success
with the series adaptation of the
Fantastic video game The Last of Us the
series was able to Thrill fans of the
game as as well as new viewers and scor
particularly well with its dedication to
the original the casting of Pedro Pascal
as Joel and Bella Ramsey as Ellie was
initially met with skepticism however
after the release of the First episodes
these doubts were immediately cleared up
the series quality not only impressed
viewers but also the television Academy
resulting in 25 Emmy nominations it
should therefore come as no surprise
that a second season will follow which
was originally due to be released in
late 2024 or early 2025 and will focus
on the events from the second part of
the video game however the Hollywood
strikes are likely to cause a delay to
the release date as production is
currently suspended filming was
originally planned to kick off at the
end of 2023 but has now been postponed
for the time being nevertheless we are
glad that the story of Joel and Ellie is
far from
Over the animated League of Legends
series Arcane proved to be an unexpected
Netflix hit in 2021 and was awarded for
Emmys since then fans have been eagerly
awaiting a second season which is still
a long time coming it has been announced
that the second season will not be
released until winter next year Riot
game CEO Nicolo commented on the plans
for the second season stating that there
were basically two reasons for the
delays firstly they wanted to take their
time in order to maintain a high level
of quality secondly production could
only begin when the success of season 1
became apparent there is no information
about the story yet but Arcane season 2
is likely to pick up where season 1
ended with a big Cliffhanger V Jinx and
Caitlyn will also be back in season 2
Arcane is set in the divided city state
of piltover which is made up of a
wealthy and an impoverished Part Two
Sisters grow up in the hostile
environment of the poor district and
commit a robbery in the rich one
triggering a chain of disastrous
events The Fallout franchise is one of
the most popular and successful
role-playing games of all time and
includes several parts and spin-offs on
the 25th anniversary of the series it
was announced that would also be adapted
into a series format Amazon acquired the
rights and will release the series next
year Christopher Nolan's brother
Jonathan who has already written the
scripts for Interstellar and Westworld
will be responsible for the screenplays
for Fallout he'll be assisted by his
wife Lisa Joy with Walton gogin the
series has already secured the
involvement of a well-known actor
according to early speculation the
series is about the survivors of Vault
33 and takes place in Los Angeles a
first trailer was revealed exclusively
at this year's gamescon in Germany and
showed footage of the so-called
Brotherhood of Steel it is therefore
only a matter of time before the general
public can also enjoy the first moving
images in the meantime the release date
has also been set the Fallout series
will debut on Amazon Prime video on
April 12th
2024 this news was a bombshell The
Legend of Zelda is being adapted for the
big screen as a liveaction movie after
the Super Mario Brothers movie this time
Nintendo is teaming up with Sony to put
together what appears to be a very big
project the expectations are huge as the
Zelda games are one of the most beloved
franchises ever the director is West
ball who made a name for himself with
the Maze Runner and will soon be in
charge of kingdom of the Planet of the
Apes the script was written by Derek
Connelly who already has some experience
of video game adaptations thanks to
detective Pikachu the search for
suitable leading actors will surely not
be an easy task after all Link and Zelda
are two absolute icons in the gaming
world after the announcement of the
movie in November 2023 it will certainly
take some time before the Legend of
Zelda will finally hit theaters we can
hardly
wait in addition to Fallout Amazon will
also be behind another series adaptation
that is expected to raise high
expectations the talk is of god of war
in 2022 the head of Sony television
Studios Katherine Pope revealed that
work had begun on the series rumors were
already circulating on the xplatform
that Dwayne Johnson could possibly
assume the role of the main character
Kratos however Johnson immediately
denied the rumors The Last of Us is sure
to have raised the bar for adaptations
of well-known Sony games it is feasible
however that God of War will prove to be
similarly successful uccessful the story
and popularity of the games certainly
suggests so when exactly we can expect
the God of War series is still
uncertain Splinter Cell agent Sam fiser
is to return as part of a series but in
a different way than expected the
adaptation of Splinter Cell will not be
a liveaction adaptation but instead an
anime series from Netflix Derek colat
who has previously worked as a writer
for John Wick will write and produce the
series The Netflix series will initially
comprise two seasons with a total of 16
episodes and will tell the story of US
Navy SEAL Sam Fischer who is recruited
by the NSA to work for the ominous Third
Echelon directorate within the agency
the core elements of the game involved
complex levels in which fer was guided
through various missions in stealth mode
with tactics and skill being the most
important factors it remains to be seen
whether the adaptation will incorporate
these elements the series doesn't have a
release date as of
yet so these were all the video game
adaptations we are most looking forward
to what are your top favorites and are
there any other video games that you
think should definitely be made into
films let us know in the
[Music]
comments